a nome de merda non si può dare manco
l'intonazione devi dire per forza a
tutti ragazzi e prevenuto questo video
sono vari j
oggi siamo su week partiamo da capo che
non ho visto un paio di robin giro deve
essere peggio this land e cioè la roba
in una foresta in teoria questo viking
dei teenager entrano nel bosco certo la
mezzanotte
ovviamente 1 e bendato ovviamente
bendati fantastico ci vediamo alle 6 del
mattino se sopravvivete di cipro che
questa cosa delle 6 del mattino è
diventata un punto fisso nei videogiochi
ci siamo ragazzi dovevo devo non so
bello avevo cobain darvi i ragazzi non
sapremo mai chi ci ha portati qua ma
fotte sega prendiamo la cannella pick up
candle si vedono anche le braccia è una
figata così l'ho vista solo in the
forest che tratta la grafica è uguale on
heaven's lander man l'attenzione che gli
indizi sono evoluti adesso la carta
svolazza c'è proprio bello e si vede la
mano che prende le cose che bello ma è
normale trovare queste cose nella
foresta ci serve ram non pensare gori ma
non pensare a cosa che non penso corro
corro a parete ragazzi sto andando sono
stanco soccorso tre secondi
la [ __ ] porca [ __ ]
cos'era fermi michia bruttissimo ma che
nascerà un barcellona che lo smiley no
vabbè bruttissimo cos'è
ma chi c'è ma è normale premier perché
la candela si scioglie giusto certo la
fisica in sto gioco è fantastico best
gioco horror è ver
no no no no fermi che prima è successa
una roba brutta non corro corro corno
pensare cori non pensare gori 6
impostato veramente così costi spaventi
e pazzesco non ho mai visto un gioco
horror fatto così il fuoco e caldo
quindi qualcuno è passato di quali
recente protesterò la team che è tim
lui mi ha sentito 92 dove non lo vedo
vedo non lo vedeva non lo vedevo cieli
sogno ciao sale se un bambino le chiazze
cosa casa addestrandoli che ti denuncio
la famiglia anche punti su produrre il
cane grazie e grano nobile me lo
ricorderò il prossimo natale
nella spada laser lista rossa dall'inzio
nar culo altro che regala stata forza
ragazzi quelli di un bambino mi uccido
proviamo un'altra strada visto che prima
sono andato da quella parte lì comunque
visto altra altro le pagine non la devo
riprendere me l'ha già presa e
bellissimo ha fatto troppo bene nel
senso non è neanche ripetitivo
[Musica]
stava ricordando posso prendere questa
maschera di v per vendetta ho capito
quello che hai detto e condivido in
pieno
un altro grazie d altro canto è bello
fame gambia
[Musica]
porca [ __ ] ma perché si deve essere
così stronzo da dove che parte devo
andare ma non mi ricordo più sarà caldo
mi ricordo più da che parte sono
arrivato fantastica con il nico a lui ha
mangiato al mcdonald è talmente tanto
che non peso che se fa due passi e morto
la resistenza di mia nonna proprio i
complimenti un divano e più economico di
quelli che danno agli creati da 50 euro
non di più è per sta roba
bye bye bye bye bye bye bye bye bye bye
lei non va preso non mi sta prendendo
nomi sta prendendo prova con la
resistenza di un criceto
[Musica]
ok non c'è più è sparito a caso la mente
corre zio sono cori sei morto tudico
ogni grasso 6 spider man
porca [ __ ] cori non poco la vacca
laida zoza a sono vivo mi ha preso il
mio figlio sto camminando ma sono vivo
che una domanda celano augura ce l'ho io
se mi finisce la candela che succede
tanto stima mix di alacce di ciò gli
accendini o profitto di fare la domanda
me e mi è finita la candela geniale
prendi la veloce però bravo un autobus
questo è un autobus è un riconosciuto la
distanza che non autobus non so
compromesso ma qui c'è l'autobus dei
simpson
questo era il posto di team ma chi è
quel tipo belloccio che vi è saltato
addosso tipo spiderman prima lobby teme
lo è perché nel caso non è
simpaticissimo cioè proprio non è
cavalca laida corre deficiente ok ok ti
sei ripreso all'ultimo secondo di più
non mi ha raggiunto se non mi ha
raggiunto prima ora cerchio non era solo
la prima ora durata un'ora vera c'è tra
questo ed emily once to play quale che
fa più brutto è una zona diversa si vede
dai disegni stay away sai lontano da lei
pagarne che ci avessi tutto sta voglia
di vedere saba mi va beh sì perché no
guardi sto cazzo è il brano quindi non è
cambiato niente fosse sempre quello il
lian chi a liliane era pian piano si
aggiungono i nomi al bus fantastico tira
fuori il fiammifero tira fuori
fiammifero ok
che cazzo cosa che cosa cazzo è via via
via via via scena famiglia che fluttua
c'è una bambina che è sparita notava una
bambina che fluttuavano il momento
peggiore della storia perché non ci
manca la candela fantastico radici in
una veloce veloce veloce veloce veloce
veloce veloce io santiddio via via via
via via via via via
accendi
no no no no no non ci sono andato a
vederlo
non fregato manco io così per le
verifiche di matematica lo fai turno sta
andando ragazzi dove sto andando
spiegate nei venti minuti ci dovreste 20
minuti costa gente e devo resistere papa
fan cuore va dai c'è un bambino di merda
su un bambino di merda mi fai anche il
bello che io perdo anche il punto dove
stavo guardando non so non mi ritrovo
più si deficienti bastano mi fa fare
così e non vedo più dove stava andando
porca vacca incredibile non svegliarlo
alla quella quella cosa di prima
indicava un nuovo tipo di nemico quindi
adesso c'è un altro tipo di nemico che
non devo svegliare bello ogni ogni ora
si aggiungono nemici finché non arriva
alla sesta se riesco a farla poi faccio
un secondo episodio sul sul mio pene di
online di will wait la tua luce lo
sveglieranno
da lascio qui poi il penny che vuoi
[Musica]
santo iddio santo iddio
e questo il tizio che bello che bello
che bello sì sì di una mano a fare i
compiti mai chiesto gentilmente go back
to sleep torna a dormire sana e l'ha
lasciata lì a eli eli eli è lì l'ho
lasciata a terra e terra ea terra la
terra è a terra la terra che succede
questo succede questo succede questo
succede questo non lo sto guardando non
lo sto guardando che è imposto per fede
ring ci manca solo quello mi è finita la
grande out perdincibacco che sfortuna è
finita l'ora che magari mag assieme a me
tanta troppo lontane raiola come ci
arrivo cazzo est a candele burundi dove
sono
grazie a dio non è possibile non ci sto
credendo mai
no no no
cosa carica bianco sapian chi no no no
no ero alla fine porca vacca per alla
fine regala non ci credo non ci credo
alla fine ho resistito sei anni sia
arrivata alla fine non ci credo come
cazzo faccia se non l'ho sentito che lo
stava che ne so io devo fare la terza
ordinaria dalla sesta quindi devo fare
ancora 3 4 5 ragazzi lo faccio nel
prossimo episodio comunque volevo fare
un commento così a freddo figo ma tanto
ce ne sono un vedere un gioco horror
fatto così bene da emily mons to play
che era quello di cinque giorni fa
spero che il video vi sia piaciuto e
cosa se il momento è un mi piace anche a
facili facebook e con il video
prescrizione se si rischia di cv da un
passo video ricordatevi che se russa the
cioè se io russo non mi mettete le luci
perché vi muore il criceto bella buio